we're now getting close to the end of
our study of
certain kierkegaard's philosophical
fragments and we're focusing on
yet another sort of joint part of the
the
composition something in between the
chapters
previously we looked at an appendix to
chapter three
that was a bridge between chapter three
and chapter four
now we're looking at this part that he
calls an interlude between
chapter four and chapter five and
chapter four
was the case of the contemporary
disciples so it had to do with
how it was that a person who would be
present at what has come to be known as
the the christ event but
it's kind of misleading to call an event
since it takes place over
over time but the idea is that the
people who are able to
participate in and be present at the
sort of coming into being of the eternal
the
the eruption of the eternal into
time and history and we saw
why this would be something that could
make
sense from from kierkegaard's
perspective something that reason could
even grasp although it had to grasp this
as a paradox
and then the contemporary disciple
couldn't just be
anybody and there are certain types of
knowledge that the contemporary disciple
um would be less inclined to be be
involved with
and
you know we talked about how how they
would apprehend this through
through what kierkegaard is calling
faith and he has his own particular
understanding of
of faith which we'll go into a little
bit more
now the interlude is a joint like i said
between
the contemporary disciple so people
around the time of
of christ and the disciple at second
hand
which is what chapter 5 the last chapter
of the work is about
who is the disciple at second hand well
would be somebody like kierkegaard
or would be somebody else who
sees things the same way lives the same
kind of life in relation to
to the paradox to god
so he says that he's again addressing
the reader
let us now assume this teacher has made
his appearance he's dead and buried in
that some time intervenes between
chapters four and chapter five
likewise it sometimes happens in a
comedy that several years elapsed
between two successive acts
in order to indicate this passage of
time the orchestra is occasionally made
to play a symphony or the light for
shortening the time and filling it with
music
so he's using a dramatic
metaphor here and he says i'm not going
to fill it with music
i'm going to fill it with with words and
what kind of words does he actually pick
well this is probably the most
metaphysical and most
sort of explicitly philosophical
portions of the work so you know if this
is philosophical fragments
here we're actually dealing with
something that's like straight out
metaphysics
um dealing with time eternity coming to
being
to a certain extent some epistemology
dealing with the question of knowledge
and what is knowledge what isn't
knowledge
so it's kind of a funny little interlude
if
if you're following this metaphor so he
says
how long this interval should be i'm
content to leave to your discretion
but if it seems agreeable to you let us
in a spirit of jest and earnest assume
that
precisely 1843 years have
have elapsed why that number that's when
he's writing this
right so how many years since the the
now notice he's not talking about the
the
crucifixion he's not talking about um
the ministry of christ or anything like
that
he's charting this from the incarnation
which is kind of interesting he's not
going to talk a lot
about that per se he's talking about the
teacher is actually going around
teaching but he's
actually charting this from the point
where
god enters into to time in a determinant
way
so he says you'll know what i ought to
proceed somewhat leisurely if only for
the sake of the illusion for
that number of years eighteen hundred
and forty three years and it is an
exceptionally generous allotment of time
likely to put me in a predicament the
opposite of that in which our
philosophers find ourselves and he means
the philosophers of the contemporary
time
whom the time usually permits only an
indication of their meaning
and the opposite also to that of our
historians who find
that not the material but the time
leaves them in the lurch because there's
such a big gap
for them i do not by any means doubt
that you have completely understood an
ascendant to the newest philosophy so
the hegelian
idealism right
which like the modern age generally
seems to suffer from a curious
distraction confusing
promise with performance the
superscription with the execution
for what age and what philosophy was
ever so wonderful and wonderfully great
as our own
in superscription so you know what he's
what he's saying there again
sort of a barb before we actually begin
is that one of the problems with
philosophy is that it has a tendency
to declare certain problems
settled certain solutions discovered
and it issues a lot of promissory notes
that that oftentimes when you start
reading
it can't back up you know for my
for on my part i i'd be less inclined to
look to hegel
and more inclined to look to somebody
like contour spinoza
you know both of them are very
influential
on hegel spinoza just makes declarations
well this is the way it is and you know
this is the way we have to understand
things from now now on
and for a long time everyone says well
that's you know we're not going to buy
that but then a lot of people start
buying it
and you'll find people who who will you
know cite spinoza and quote spinoza as
if
well that's just the the last word on
things
um thankfully not too many of them and
he's got you know a sort of deductive
process that actually turns out to have
all sorts of gaps in it when you look at
it carefully
kant is also kind of you know funny
along those lines because
he not only declares large parts of
former philosophy
basically off limits he's sort of like a
a global building inspector of
philosophy
who gets to condemn whatever he wants
and say no no don't do anything over
there
that's no longer any good only over here
but when he provides you explanations of
things i often find
huge gaps in his own explanations where
he doesn't seem to see
that his explanations wouldn't be
satisfying you know
for instance i've never been able to
fully grasp precisely what it is that
kant means by
by desire and it's something that i i
grasped perfectly well
at least experientially maybe it's
something
sort of like augustine's conception of
time where i
can't give you a articulate conception
of it if i'm
asked to do so but
i seem to operate pretty well in it
well kierkegaard is saying that a lot of
the philosophy of his time is suffering
from the same sort of
defects or deficits that
it doesn't make good on his promises
we're going to see
why in part because he's going to be
tying those kinds of philosophy
with necessity and with essence or or
with
what he's going to call cognition and
he's going to say that they
are unable to really grasp what's going
on
in faith so now that we've discussed the
the whole point of the the interlude and
some of the preliminary material
let's look at these these different
parts there are four parts to this
and the first three parts are actually
fairly quick
but we don't want to go through them you
know too quickly and lose sight of
what's going on here
because this is some fairly high level
pretty important commitment being made
kind of metaphysics going on here
kierkegaard is
actually acting as a straight out
philosopher
comparing his own views to to those of
other classic philosophers including
aristotle plato
of course hegel and and
the greek skeptics descartes some of
these other
great thinkers throughout time so he's
making sense out of
something and he starts out by
considering the
question of change so this is you know
again
pretty big stuff aristotle starts out in
metaphysics
basically after he goes through a
lengthy historical review
talking about the different kinds of
changes and metaphysics
is in a certain respect it's about
what's
necessary what has to be what lies
beyond all of the appearances
and contingencies but it's also about
coming to understand change what it
really is
the physics for aristotle is about
change too it's about the natural
world and i suppose you could say the
ethics the politics all these other
works are also about
change of a different sort but the
metaphysics is about the nature of
change itself
and here we're getting into that very
field so he says
in what sense is there change in that
which comes into existence
so he's not talking about the necessary
we're going to see him draw a complete
wedge
between that which is necessary and that
which comes into existence
it says what is the nature of the coming
into existence kind of change
so there's more than one type of change
and these are fundamentally different
categories there's a coming into
existence kind of change and then he
says all other change
becoming other becoming different
becoming alien
presupposes the existence of that which
changes even when the change
consistencies seem to exist
so this is a really important point to
get straight about
from the beginning let's take this
pencil for example
now this pencil exists right you know
because you're seeing it right now
it may cease to exist by the time that
we're actually viewing this or
we're showing this depending on how long
these videos last
i'm guaranteed it's going to outlast
this this pencil now this pencil has
certain qualities right it's made of
certain things
it's got this eraser it's got this
graphite part
as i rub with it it wears down that is a
change that's a becoming different
as it shortens as i sharpen it more and
more that's becoming different it is a
color the color could change
it could something could react with this
paint and turn it white turn it black
turn it you know spotted colors it could
mold it could you know all sorts of
things could occur to it
the wood itself i suppose could undergo
certain things
if i bite down on it like this i'm
changing it in a certain way
right that's all becoming other that all
presupposes that there's something
already there
there's a there's another type of change
and i don't want to say that it's
necessarily more fundamental
metaphysically because these are all
very fundamental
um but it is different coming into
existence is different
you know anything that involves this
pencil the pencil already exists
what was it that brought this into
existence
now we're looking at a different kind of
process
a different kind of basis so he says
um you can't say
that there is you know already something
which
changes with coming into existence
because it's about existing right
he says if the subject of coming into
existence does not
itself remain unchanged during the
change of coming into existence
that which comes into existence is not
this subject which comes into existence
but something else
now that's a little bit tricky to wrap
your head around so
what does he what does he mean there
he's saying that
whatever it is that's coming into
existence
once it actually does come into
existence its nature must be
what what it actually is or else
something else came into existence
later on he's going to talk about this
in terms of different possibilities
so he says a little bit further on
coming to existence change is not a
change in
essence see
it's possible for some things that are
changing by becoming other to change
in essence biting this does not change
its essence
right i suppose reducing it to powder
would change its its essence if i were
just to
you know or grinding this up into to you
know bits or something like that
it would no longer have the form of a
pencil it would no longer have the same
sort of purpose
coming to coming into existence kind of
change is not a change in
essence but in being and as a transition
from not existing to existing
so then he gets a little bit more
technical here he says this non-being
which is this
which the subject of coming into
existence leaves behind
so you know when something comes into
existence first it doesn't exist
then it's going to exist so it has
non-being here
and now over here and i understand we're
doing spatial things so it's not quite
you know
perfect yet when it becomes
something that is real something that
does exist
it now has being so what about this
non-being that it left behind he says
this non-being must itself have some
sort of being
that's a very radical metaphysical
move and i think a lot of people won't
really realize what kierkegaard is doing
at that point
he's saying that non-being of the thing
which comes into existence
has a certain kind of being so he's he's
actually
floating the possibility of broaching
the law of identity the law of the
excluded middle
these these fundamental you know rules
of logic or thought
kierkegaard's metaphysics is one which
actually is consistent
but is kind of hard to wrap your head
around unless you're paying very close
attention to what's going on so he says
otherwise the subject of coming into
existence would not remain unchanged
during the change of coming into
existence
unless it had not been at all and then
the change of coming into existence
would for another reason be absolutely
different from every other kind of
change
since it would be no change at all for
every change
always presupposes something which
changes but such a being
which is nevertheless a non-being
is precisely what here's how he's going
to
deal with this possibility is
the kind of being that non-being
possesses the non-being
which things which come into existence
have
is possibility possibility is not
actuality aristotle realized this a long
time
ago there's a fundamental difference
between the two of them
and it's difficult to explain exactly
what possibility consistent a lot of
people when they're doing their
metaphysics
they kind of push possibility over the
other side and make it into something
like a type of actuality
kierkegaard is trying to to resist that
so he says
a being which which is being
is indeed actual being or actuality so
something that actually possesses
existence that
or possesses is really the wrong word
something that does exist now
is actual it has become actual
and the change of coming into existence
is a transition
from possibility to actuality
you notice i've written a lot of
different possibles over here you'll see
why in just a moment
now he changes here he says can the
necessary
come into existence and
some metaphysicians have thought that
the necessary
not only can come into existence but but
has come into existence you know that
there are some things that are necessary
that like say the the laws of nature for
example
they are necessary but they came into
existence at a certain time say if god
you know created them or something like
that kierkegaard rejects that kind of
view
he says anything that is actually
necessary
it is it always is
as a matter of fact it's a little bit
misleading even to say always
at every point in time it already is
because it's necessary because it
couldn't possibly be otherwise
so he says can the necessary come into
existence
well coming into existence is a change
but the necessary cannot be changed
since it always relates itself to itself
and relates itself to itself in the same
way that's what it means
to be necessary that's a fairly
dialectical or hegelian way of putting
it
and so let me read that to you one more
time it always relates itself to itself
and relates itself to itself the same
way
that's a little bit more to say that is
a little bit more than to say
it always is it it relates itself to
itself
and always in the same way so it doesn't
change
in that sense so he says all coming into
existence
to the contrary is a suffering and the
necessary cannot suffer
it cannot undergo the suffering of the
actual which is that of the possible
not only the excluded possibility when
something becomes possible
it becomes possible or when something
possible becomes
actual it does so out of a range of a
number of different possibilities
for example at one point in time
i could have gone many different ways in
my career paths
those are no longer live possibilities
for me now even though i could say take
some of them up as a second career
i can never be greg sadler
becoming uh say a daddy data entry
person
back in 1994 instead i chose a different
path at that time i actually chose to
work in a gas station and then become a
security guard and work in a cafe while
i prepared to go to graduate school
those possibilities were closed off
and one of the possibilities became
actual that's what it means
actually to exist that
we're continually continually undergoing
this process
of possibilities some of them you might
say being pinched off and one of them
sort of getting through and becoming the
one that actually
becomes the reality so he says
um everything which comes into existence
proves precisely by coming into
existence that it's not necessary
for the only thing which cannot come
into existence is the necessary because
the necessary
already is so then he
he poses this issue he says is not
necessity then a synthesis of
possibility in actuality he says
now this is sort of a typical you know
hegelian movies
what would that mean um possibility in
actuality
don't differ in essence but in being and
whether they really
exist or not how could there be
how could this difference from this
difference be formed a synthesis
constituting necessity which is not a
determination of being but a
determination of essence
since it's the essence of the necessary
to be if these two things
possibility and actuality which aren't
really things their conditions
could be united to become necessity they
would become an absolutely different
essence which is not a kind of change
and in becoming a necessity or the
necessary they would they would become
that which alone of all things excludes
coming into existence
which would not make sense then from
from
kierkegaard's perspective so you can't
overcome this
gap you can't bring them together when
he's talking about a synthesis
you can't bring possibility in actuality
together
under like one single concept that would
embrace
both of them and unite them and somehow
have its own inner necessity
instead possibility in actuality or
something much more exciting
than what is necessary
so let's go on a little bit more he says
the necessary is a category entirely by
itself nothing ever comes into existence
with necessity
likewise this the necessary never comes
into existence
coming into existence is something very
special in kierkegaard's metaphysics
that's why this is existentialism
existence matters
he says the the necessary never comes
into existence and something by coming
into existence never becomes the
necessary this is going to be a very
important point
he criticizes aristotle i'm going to
skip over that criticism very quickly
and he says the change involved in
coming into existence is actuality the
transition
you notice there's one other thing on
the board that we haven't actually
talked about yet
the transition
takes place with freedom i should put
freedom right next to this
kierkegaard is going to contrast a cause
and a rational ground or a necessary
ground
a cause in kierkegaard's metaphysics
is ultimately something free a cause is
something that determines something else
that makes it be what it is so for
example this chalk you know if we want
to think about this in terms of
aristotle's four causes it has a
material cause right it's made out of
calcium what carbonate or something like
that it has a certain
form a certain shape that it's been it
has been impressed upon it
it was brought into being by somebody
operating on some kind of machine i
suppose
to form this this chalk and it has a
certain purpose which you
see demonstrated right here right
now for kierkegaard each one of these
causes
ultimately stems from something free
we tend to think of cause as already
involving necessity or determinism or
something like that
kierkegaard says no cause by itself the
very conception of it
ultimately you know brings us back to
freedom
so he says all coming into existence
takes place with freedom
not by necessity nothing comes into
existence by virtue of a
logical ground but only by a cause
every cause terminates in a freely
affecting cause
in something choosing in something
saying yes
this not that in something closing off
again
that manifold of possibilities and
making this possibility be the one that
that burst
forth into actuality now
that's not to say that it's all
necessarily humanly caused
but that there is freedom within the
universe and not just freedom
like in one global sense but freedoms
and that these are what you know all
things ultimately trace back to
so he says every cause terminates in a
freely affecting cause
the illusion occasioned by the
intervening causes
because there's a whole chain of causes
is that the coming into existence seems
to be necessary
the truth about intervening causes is
that just as they themselves have come
into existence
they point back ultimately to a freely
affecting cause
even the possibility of deducing
consequences from a law of nature which
is you know typical of modern philosophy
right with this
whole law you know these these systems
of laws of nature and maybe they've been
reduced down to mathematics in some
people's views right
this gives no evidence for the necessity
of any coming into existence and he says
this is clear as soon as
one reflects definitively on coming into
existence
the same is the case with manifestations
of freedom
provided we do not let ourselves
be deceived by the manifestations of
freedom but reflect on the coming to
existence
but what does that mean that's this is
the very end of the
first section when we think about human
actions
which you know are are not just
coming out of freedom but in many
respects embody our freedom
sometimes we think that well if we can
provide some sort of reason for them
then they they are they're determined
they're caused
and what we're forgetting is that
there's always the play of freedom
going on with them because something is
being brought into
existence and whatever is being brought
into existence is not necessary
according to kierkegaard
let's go to the second section now now
he's going to bring up another category
the historical
he says so everything that has come into
existence
is aoipso you know by that very nature
historical for even if it accepts no
further historical predicate and
nevertheless accepts the one decisive
historical predicate
it has come into existence
he's you know he's he's going over this
fairly quickly
and you know you might be tempted when
you you hear this category the
historical
to think that what he means by that is
you know the kind of history that we
have in books
what he means is the kind of existence
that we actually live out
we live out historical existence we
exist
through time we have a past
actually like a whole jumbled up past or
you know
still trailing behind us almost like a
bunch of you know
shadows and tin cans at the same time
right
we have a present moment and then we
have a sort of future that we're headed
towards
and our history overlaps with other
people's history
it's part of the meaning of human
existence
to be historical in this sense
so he says
the historical is the past for the
present pressing upon the confines of
the future has not yet become historical
okay that makes perfect sense
how then can it be said that nature
though immediately present is historical
except in the sense of the sad ingenious
speculation
the difficulty comes from the fact he
says that nature is too abstractive a
dialectic with respect to time in the
stricter sense
nature continues on and everything that
happens in nature
is not actually happening out of
necessity you know
the kind of necessity that would always
be occurring uh
all the time but it's it's
it's not as developed right there's
there's not as much going on there
there are free causes operative but not
in the same senses with human beings
so he says coming into existence may
present a root reduplication that is the
possibility of a second
coming into existence within the first
coming into existence
so imagine this process right here
reduplicated
the possibilities being sort of
channeled into
one single one which survives all the
rest of them remain back and non-being
and that possibility then becomes
actuality
now imagine this turned in upon itself
and you have a human being a human being
that can reflect upon itself
decide what sorts of possibilities it
wants to embrace and what types it wants
to
reject can hold itself accountable for
these things can hold other human beings
accountable for these sorts of things
so he says here we have the historical
and the stricter sense
subject to a dialectic with respect to
time
and he says um
the more specifically historical coming
into existence occurs
by the operation of a relatively freely
affecting cause
now what does he mean by that he means
human being
a relatively freely affecting cause
that's a brilliant way of putting things
are we completely free as human beings
absolutely not anybody who thinks that
they're completely free or that any
other human being is completely free
has no things you know pushing them this
way or pushing them that way or drawing
them
is you know not thinking things through
very clearly
but does that mean that we don't have
any freedom at all
no we're relatively free we're a
relatively free
affecting cause bringing things from
possibility in ourselves
in the world in other people uh
in meaning all sorts of you know
different modes there from possibility
to actuality
so he says this in turn points
ultimately towards an absolutely freely
affecting cause
which would be god now he doesn't follow
this through he's not
as we've seen earlier in he's not
particularly interested in trying to
prove you know god's existence through
some sort of philosophical argument he
could actually try to do that from this
but he doesn't instead that's the end of
the section too
now he goes to section three called the
past
and here you get to see him sort of peel
back the veil and here's where he's
saying
here this is where i take my stand my
metaphysics
does not see the past as necessary and
you might say well
who cares that's not a very important
step it actually is
because there's quite a few ways of
looking at reality
and at times that
decide to see the past and things that
have occurred in the past as
not only not being able to be otherwise
than they are
but as necessarily being what they are
so he says um let's grant
that you know once something is passed
it can't be changed right
what has happened has happened it cannot
be undone
is this immutability identical with the
immutability
the unchangeability of the necessary
he says no well why not
the immutability of the past of things
in the past
you know for instance of my showing you
this pencil
rather than showing you a different
pencil
the immutability of that has been
brought about by a change
namely the change of coming into
existence
such an immutability does not exclude
all change since it didn't exclude
this change all changes excluded
only by being excluded in every moment
so if you want to say that
all change is excluded you have to say
all change is excluded from the
beginning of time all the way to the end
of time
now think about past things past things
that came into being came into being
at a point in time at the point in time
that they came into being
it had to be possible for that to be it
also had to be possible for that not to
be
or else they would be necessary right
you can't you know sort of you know
presume that they're necessary because
we're trying to work our way backwards
if they were possible if they could have
been otherwise at the point in time
where they actually occurred and now
came into being
and now can't be changed
that means that they're not necessary
because in order to be necessary they
have to be necessary throughout the
entire timeline
kierkegaard is saying so he says
how is it that we can actually think
about it as necessary
well that comes because we forget that
things have
actually come into existence we treat
them
in a different way we think about them
in a different way we forget something
when we do that
so he says the immutability of the past
consists in the fact that it's actual
thus
it's that that it is the case
that it is this way cannot become
different
but does it follow from this that it's
possible how could not have been
realized in a different manner that
another possibility with a different how
could have been the one that actually
won through now he says
the immutability of the necessary
consists in its constant relating itself
to itself in relating itself to itself
always in the same manner
excluding any change
something coming to be has a relation to
its own past
that can be different you could be
different than you are
at all different sorts of points
everything around you
could be different this video could be
shot differently
that's what makes it so you might say in
certain respects
irreplaceable that's what makes it
actual that's what gives it
the almost you know mystery he doesn't
use the word mystery here but
mystery of coming to be of existence
the necessary doesn't have that and the
necessary is what you can
sort of wrap your head around and put
into a catalog you can't put existence
into a catalog
for kierkegaard so now he says the
future
hasn't happened yet but the future is
you know no less necessary than the past
the past did not become necessary by
coming to
into existence so the future the past
the present none of them are necessary
so he says the past has come into
existence coming into existence is the
change of actuality brought about by
freedom if the past had become
necessary it would no longer belong this
is very important it would no longer
belong to freedom
it would belong to necessity if the past
and let's think about this in terms of
ourselves
if what we have made of ourselves and
our relationships with others
and our own understanding of where we've
been and where we've gone and where
we're headed to
if that became necessary
by you know coming into being
what would freedom matter once you've
used it
it's gone and it all becomes necessary
kierkegaard is holding out for a very
robust
sense of freedom here that's something
actually myself i found very attractive
in his work so he says freedom would be
in a sorry case both an object of
laughter and deserving of tears
since it would be responsible for what
it did
it would be responsible for what did not
belong to it being destined to bring
offspring into the world
for necessity to devour freedom itself
would be an illusion
and coming into existence no less so
freedom would be a witchcraft and coming
into existence a false alarm
so before we go on to the fourth and
largest section
it's worth you know thinking this over
when we do metaphysics quite often the
goal is to like arrive at some sort of
necessary scheme things must be
this way something we can sort of you
know articulate
in terms of cognitions that every
rational person could could grasp if
kierkegaard is right
that's actually a cul-de-sac that you
don't want to go
into because the best that you can do in
a cul-de-sac is keep turning around
round and round right you can't actually
go through to get to the the other side
so now we're going to look at the the
big section
you notice i've changed things on the
board around somewhat
in part because this this last section
section 4
of the interlude is where everything
comes to a crux
sections one two and three we're
bringing into
uh into sight a bunch of different
metaphysical categories
necessity freedom
temporality of past present and future
the notion of cause versus
necessary or logical or rational ground
and then possibility in actuality these
sort of classic metaphysical categories
but all of that's been leading up to
this section where
kicker guard is trying to look at how in
fact
we apprehend the past as past and here
he's going to touch on something that
has to do
very much with the nature of existence
human existence in particular
but existence as a whole in general
so he titles this section the
apprehension of the past and that's what
he's actually starting with
you notice i've written a lot of
different qualifications that that apply
to the past
that that come up in this chapter so i'm
going to run through these
very quickly the past
for kierkegaard and this may seem like a
trivial point at first but it's not
is what has come into existence so
there's something special about coming
into existence
we've already seen that anything that
comes into existence is
going to be something that's quite
different than that which is necessary
or a necessity
it involves some sort of free cause
ultimately
um so that leads to the second point
it's not necessary and it never becomes
so
the past for kierkegaard is a you know
very
firm philosophical and metaphysical
commitment
just because the past is past and has
happened and is fixed doesn't mean that
it's actually necessary
third point is that it involves this
play between certainty and uncertainty
and we'll see how that works out in
just a little bit another thing that
comes in here
that we're going to explore a bit as
well is that he says there's a
passionate
sense an emotion that applies to this
and that's wonder
and that is particularly important
because
in a lot of philosophers we know from
them philosophy begins in wonder right
so we're going to want to look at that
another key characteristic is that the
past is not given
as the past to us through the census
uh that might be a little
counterintuitive at first but we'll see
what he means by that and then
ultimately it's going to involve
at least for certain aspects of the past
it's going to involve
faith or belief and human freedom
so this is where
a lot of things are going to come to a
not
as we as we saw before he starts off by
saying nature is a spatial order has
only an immediate existence
so what does that mean
what it means is that nature doesn't
have a
past in the way that culture history
human beings have a past you know sure
you can go and find
fossils and you can you know cut trees
down to the ring so there's traces of
of processes that went on
all those are contingent none of those
are absolutely necessary kierkegaard
would say
but they don't have a meaning to them
we give them meaning we
find them and and make something of them
they don't by themselves have what he
would call a dialectical
progression or they're not dialectically
involved
so he says everything that admits of a
dialectic with respect to time
is characterized by a certain duality in
that after having been present it can
persist
as past so this is something very
different
the human being has a past that you
could think of as trailing behind them
again we have to resort to these spatial
metaphors in order to make sense of
these these
sorts of things so the human being
has a past human cultures have a past
human groups have a past um
they were originally present and that's
that's a point which is going to be very
important to keep in mind
when we look at you know the the way in
which
coming to be or coming into existence
works
so he says the essentially historical is
always the past
why because it's already over right it's
already taken place
and as past it has its own actuality
for the fact that it's happened is
certain and dependable
so we're seeing this play of certainty
there right
it's certain it's dependable caesar
crossed the rubicon
abraham lincoln was shot i did you know
hold a job
at 100 east wisconsin uh in 1994 in 1995
those are sort of fixed points and
nothing is going to change those
he says but the fact that it has
happened is on the other hand the ground
of un
uncertainty by which the apprehension
will always be prevented from
assimilating the past as if it had been
thus from all eternity
so what does he mean there about
uncertainty does that mean that
now suddenly we can say well maybe i
didn't do that maybe abraham lincoln
wasn't shot everything turns into like a
grand
conspiracy theory or we all become
skeptics
that's not what kierkegaard is saying
he's saying that
for any past event anything which came
into being
came into existence it didn't have to be
that way
it could have been otherwise that's what
it means to be able to come into
existence
so how is this going to play out
like he says only in terms of this
conflict between certainty and
uncertainty the distinguishing mark
of all that has come into existence and
hence also the past can the past be
understood
so in order for us to understand what it
is for something to actually be
passed we have to understand this this
play of certainty and uncertainty
we have to grasp the what we would call
contingency
of the the past thing
so he says when the past is understood
in any other manner what would be other
manners well
some of the manners of certain
philosophers certain theologians
who see the past is completely
determined and is necessitated
the apprehension has misunderstood
itself in the role of apprehension
and it has misunderstood its object as
if anything such could be the object of
an
apprehension every apprehension of the
past which proposes to understand it
better by construing it
has only the more thoroughly
misunderstood it so again you know
if if you want a metaphor for this
imagine somebody
who says i am going to go look for a
nail and they go off and instead of
looking for a nail they look for screws
and when they find a screw they say oh
i've got a nail
well no they didn't actually find a nail
what they did is misconstrue it in the
very process
of looking for it and finding it
so
he says the past is not necessary since
it came into existence
it did not become necessary by coming
into existence
so this is going back to this point when
the past came into existence it
assumed a certain fixity but that fixity
doesn't make it necessary it doesn't
make it have to have been that way
from all eternity he says still less
does it become necessary through
somebody's apprehension of it and here
he's targeting
i would say the materialistic
philosophers on the one hand and some of
the idealistic philosophers like hegel
on the other hand
it's not the case that by
by our understanding it we thereby
provide to it a kind of necessity that
it didn't have before
and he talks about a kind of
intellectual illusion that's similar to
an optical illusion you remember too we
talked about acoustic illusions before
back in the the appendix now actually
we're looking at
an optical kind of illusion he says
distance in time
tends to promote this illusion just like
distance in space
provokes a sensory illusion a
contemporary
does not perceive the necessity of what
comes into existence
why not because the contemporary is
there the contemporary knows that things
could be different
because they were there they actually
saw that it could have gone this way or
could have gone this way there was a
whole range of possibilities
that got shrunk down to one which then
became actuality
which became the one which prevailed
what happens though with distance well
distance and time centuries intervening
between the event and the beholder
suddenly we start to think that things
are necessary so we look at rome and we
say well
ancient rome had to fall but it didn't
have to fall
and we you know we say abraham lincoln
had to have been assassinated well
that's a little bit of a tougher one
because there's a lot of events that
could have changed and been differently
but we we see
some sort of internal necessity to these
quite often
so he says if the past became necessary
through being apprehended
then the apprehension would actually be
changing things the object of
apprehension would be changed as well
so he goes on and he says whoever
apprehends the past historical
philosophers that is as a philosopher of
history
again targeting hegel and people like
him is therefore a prophet in retrospect
that is a prophet expresses the fact
that the certainty of the past is based
on
an uncertainty what does he mean there
again
the certainty that the past has taken
the fixity
the the determination of it it exists on
a ground
of possibility it could have been
otherwise now it can't be otherwise at
this point in time but at the time
when it was present when it was
developing when it was occurring there
were other possibilities which were not
realized
so he says the historian then
when he encounters the past he has to
encounter it
through an emotion and this is a really
interesting observation
because what he's bringing up here this
is going to lead us to the sense of
wonder
what he's bringing up here has to do not
only with the historian but also with
the philosopher
also with the theologian the religious
person in general
and you might say that there's a nexus
tying all these together that's not
being
explicitly spelled out here but which
could be
looked at at this at this point could be
highlighted at this point
so he says um the historian thus again
confronts the past moved by the emotion
which is the passionate
sense for coming into existence we have
a sense
we have a way of apprehending coming
into existence
and that way of apprehending it is not
primarily a
solely intellectual thing it's something
that is effective it touches us in the
heart it has to do with you know the
very
depth of our being and he says what is
that that's wonder
now that should make us think at this
point
about aristotle's victim
that philosophy also begins in wonder
that from the beginning and he's saying
this actually in the metaphysics
from the beginning we we wondered at
things we wondered at say natural
phenomenon
or we wondered we were in amazement we
we
were stupefied by we wanted to
understand we were provoked towards
a kind of awe towards
well the very the very fact of being
itself
or things being how they are and not
having turned out otherwise
these are all things that we can feel
wonder at and so the historian
feels wonder and he says if the
philosopher never finds occasion to
wonder
he has nothing to do with historical for
wherever the process of coming into
existence is involved as
is the case in relation to the past
they're the uncertainty attaching to the
most certain of events the uncertainty
of coming into existence
can find expression only in this passion
that's a key point too
it can find its expression only in this
passion not in some other passion not in
say anger
not in indignation not in sadness
not an even joy only
in wonder
so he says this is as necessary to the
philosopher as it is worthy of him
even if the event is certain in the
extreme even if wonder offers its
consent in advance
saying that if this had not happened it
would have to be invented like you know
for example
uh people said that about the idea of
god that you know voltaire was very
famous for saying this if god did not
exist he would have to be invented
even though the passion of wonder would
fall into contradiction with itself
he says let's go on from here
so much for the apprehension of the past
we have in the meanwhile presuppose the
knowledge of the past is given
because we do in fact have knowledge of
the past how is such
not how is such knowledge to be acquired
he says the historical cannot be given
to the senses
that's a really interesting thing to say
because you know what do we think about
when we think of history
we think of people writing down what it
is that they observed
right observed through the census
so if history is just a record of
things that took place things that
occurred
and we look for say eyewitnesses
aren't we relying on them and their
senses
and the records of what it is that they
perceive through the census
well kierkegaard says yes and no
he says the historical cannot be given
immediately to the census that doesn't
mean that we
our senses aren't involved but they're
not given immediately to the senses
since the elusiveness of coming into
existence is involved in it
i'm going to repeat that because that's
a very important way of
framing it the elusiveness
of coming into existence
is involved in it there's two things
here
coming into existence is not the same
thing
as simply being coming into existence
means
being able to arise
out of a ground of possibility that
precluded other possibilities
so what do we have here he says the
immediate impression of a natural
phenomenon or of an event is not the
impression of the historical so what
we're seeing
when something occurs is not the
historical yet
the coming into existence involved
cannot be sensed immediately
but only the immediate presence but the
presence of the historical
includes the process of coming into
existence
and he says here we're actually going to
make a little detour into to
epistemology the theory of knowledge
and he says immediate sensation and
immediate cognition cannot deceive
this is by itself enough to show that
the historical cannot be the object of
either
why not because the historical has the
elusiveness
that is implicit
in all coming into existence
it eludes us it gets away from us
it's the sort of thing that we perceive
you might say out of the corner of our
eye it's that
additional surplus which is given to the
events that constitutes their their true
meaning that's very hard to pin down
very hard to articulate so he uses the
example of a star he says
when the observer sees a star the star
becomes involved in doubt the moment he
seeks to become aware
of its having come into existence
so much then is clear the organ for the
historical must have a structure
analogous with the historical itself
it must comprise a corresponding
somewhat
by which it may repeatedly negate in its
certainty
the uncertainty that corresponds to the
uncertainty of coming into existence
that's that's a mouthful so let's let's
go through that again very slowly
and figuring out what he's trying to say
there right
the historical and the apprehension of
the historical
must inc must comprise a corresponding
somewhat
i'm not even sure exactly what that
means by which it may repeatedly negate
in its certainty so
while the historical events themselves
are fixed
they have taken place you can rely on
them they have certainty
they negate in its certainty the
uncertainty that corresponds to the
uncertainty of coming into existence so
it negates
the well it could have been different
it negates the well you know this really
doesn't matter that much
because it could have been all these
other different different ways
it imbues it with a kind of greater
certainty
as he says so he goes on and he says
what is this this uncertainty this
uncertainty of coming into existence he
says it's twofold
the nothingness of the antecedent
non-being
is one side of it now remember what was
the antecedent non-being
all these other possibilities that are
not realized all
that was the ground of non-being he said
even that non-being has a certain kind
of being and that being is what
possibility
so the nothingness of that is one side
of it while the annihilation of the
possible is another
the latter being at the same time the
annihilation of every other possibility
you might say that in every single
choice
every single action every single
decision every single juncture every
single event
a kind of miracle is taking place a
metaphysical miracle
in which this range of possibilities
which don't actually have being they are
non-being
but a peculiar kind of non-being that
isn't
fully non-being right suddenly our are
dissolved
or taken away or
compressed into one single possibility
like he says the annihilation of every
other possibility
when we make a choice and something
radically new
something important comes into being
as a result we realize one possibility
and all the other possibilities suddenly
lose their status as possibilities
that happens in every single case of
something that comes into existence
so history is just full of these moments
in which this occurs
so here's where he makes a transition to
talking about faith
and he says faith has precisely the
required character
for the certainty of belief there is
always
present a negated uncertainty in every
way corresponding to the uncertainty of
coming into existence
faith believes what it does not see it
does not believe the star is there
for that it sees but it believes that
the star has come into existence
the same holds true of an event the what
of a happening
may be known immediately through the
census right you can just
perceive what's going on but by no means
can it be known
immediately that it has happened its
significance
what it means for it to be this event
this realized possibility rather than
these other realized possibilities
so he says the elusiveness pertaining to
an event consists
in its having happened in which fact
lies the transition from nothing
from non-being and from the manifold
possible
how the all the different range of
possibilities
something comes into existence every
time something comes into existence
the appropriate response to that
according to kierkegaard
is wonder so he says immediate sensation
and immediate cognition have no
suspicion of the uncertainty
with which belief approaches its object
but
neither do they suspect the certainty
which emerges from this uncertainty
and here he goes into a sort of long
digression that i'm not going to go
through all of
where he's talking about skepticism and
greek skepticism and the thing that i
want to draw from this
is just this doubt can be overcome
only by a free act an act of will he
says
why well because doubt does not emerge
from necessity doubt itself is a
free act of the doubting person it is a
choice
sometimes people say oh i can't possibly
have any sort of belief i you know
there's nothing i can rely on
kierkegaard would say well that's
actually a choice on your part you're
acting like the skeptics of old times
who actually were at least
self-conscious in their doubting
you know if you if you look at descartes
i don't want to spend too much time on
this but if you actually look at
descartes
he has to work really really hard in
order to carry out this project of
hyperbolic doubt and in the transition
from the first to the second meditation
he actually says hey i gotta take a
break because i'm not able to keep this
up
now maybe that's just a literary device
but i don't think that it is
i think that kierkegaard is right that
both belief or
faith and doubt involve an act of will
involves some sort of drive choice
decision made on the part of the person
who
who has them so he says if that's the
case
what's the upshot of this for knowledge
well it now becomes easy to see that
belief is not a form of knowledge
but a free act and expression of will it
believes the fact of coming into
existence and has thus succeeded in
overcoming within itself the uncertainty
that corresponds to the
nothingness of the antecedent non-being
the range of possibilities
it believes the thus of what has come
into existence
and it has consequently succeeded in a
nulling within itself
the possible how without denying the
possibility of another thus
the present thus is for belief most
certain
so if this is the case then faith is
something which we could have
not only in you know god or or you know
a religious text or something like that
but uh more generally for kierkegaard
at least for the kicker guard of this
text
i'm going to go on now and he says
when we have faith or when we have
belief
we're not inferring from effect to cause
so we don't see you know for example the
works of god and then say aha i
recognize those are the works of god
because they have to have a certain
cause like that the way thomas aquinas's
proofs for example work he says
i cannot sense or know immediately that
what i sense or know
immediately is an effect this is very
interesting too
what this means is that
in order to grasp metaphysical
principles at work to grasp the
metaphysical or to use somebody else's
word sapiential dimension
of things which is just as real as their
surfaces and just as real as our
thoughts of them
in order to grasp these aspects of them
we have to go beyond just the immediate
senses
and beyond immediate cognition or or you
know
rationality so he says
i believe that it is an effect now
notice belief
involves an act of the will in order to
grasp something as an effect as
an effect of a metaphysical cause
you actually have to choose that on some
level you have to
allow yourself at least to be open to
that interpretation
so he says i believe that it is an
effect for in order to bring it under
this category i must have already made
it doubtful
with the uncertainty implicit in coming
into existence
when belief resolves to do this doubt
has been overcome
in that very instance the indifference
of doubt the
sort of everything being sort of put in
suspense what he calls an equilibrium
has been dispelled not by knowledge
not by being given the one thing that
will clear up everything
but by will by choice by commitment
by decision very important point here
something that brings kierkegaard into
contact with say pascal or james or
a number of other important philosophers
so he says thus it will be seen that
belief is the most disputable of things
well in the process of approximation so
you know if
one's belief depends on well if if i get
a little bit more evidence then i'll
believe a little bit more
and then a little bit more and a little
bit more
it becomes very doubtful in that case
that's not what he thinks belief
really ought to be like he says it's the
least disputable
when one's constituted by virtue of its
new quality belief is the opposite of
doubt
belief and doubt are not two forms of
knowledge
for neither of them is a cognitive act
that's getting really interesting so now
belief and doubt involve acts of will
neither are a cognitive act
what does that leave open
well the realm of the effective
passion emotion desire
he says they are opposite passions
belief is a passion doubt is a passion
they both involve drive desire
mood the very depths of our of our being
the way in which we grasp existence as
existence
so he says belief is a sense for coming
into existence and doubt is a
protest against every conclusion that
transcends immediate sensation and
immediate cognition
so really we have three things we have
sensation
which can only tell us what we what we
perceive cognition which can only tell
us what we think
and hopefully these kind of connect up
together
and then we have what comes into
existence and
belief is what is needed to grasp that
as what comes into existence not just
how it looks
not just how we think about it but in
its very contingency in its
the fact that it didn't have to go that
way in its gratuitousness you might
say in its being in its historical
existence
so he goes on and he he says
um at no time does the past become
necessary just as it was not
necessary when it came into existence
nor revealed itself as necessary to the
contemporary who believed it
that is believed that it had come into
existence for belief in coming into
existence correspond to one another
and are concerned with two the two
negative determinations of being
namely the past and the future and with
the present
in so far it is conceived by the point
of view
of a negative determination of being
namely as having come into existence
necessity on the other hand is wholly a
matter of essence
and thus it is of the essence of the
necessary to exclude coming into
existence it can never
come into existence the necessary and
that's what our
thought grasps is the necessary
not that which surpasses it
you can ask yourself at this point well
where does god fit into all of this he
hasn't really brought that up yet
god is going to be beyond the necessary
for kierkegaard
let me go now into the the supplement
his application he says
what has been what has here been said
applies to the historical and the direct
and ordinary sense
whose only contradiction is that it has
come into existence
which contradiction is implicit in all
coming into existence
and he specifies here in a footnote what
he means by contradiction
he says don't take it in hegel's sense
where contradiction actually has the
power to produce something you know
thesis
antithesis synthesis this whole process
of
of negativity he says as long as nothing
has come into existence the
contradiction is merely the impulsive
power in the passion of wonder
when the process of coming into
existence has occurred the contradiction
is again present
as the nieces of the wonder and the
passion which reproduces the coming into
existence
so when he's talking about his
contradiction here you should actually
think
of this this process this feeling of of
wonder
now he actually does end up talking
about god he says
let us now return to our story and to
our hypothesis that the god
has been god has come into existence
god has erupted into our our temporal
historical frame
and he says as far as the direct and
ordinary form of the historical is
concerned
we have seen this that this cannot
become historical for immediate
sensation
or for cognition either for a
contemporary or for a successor
so what can it then be available to
how can we apprehend this
through faith he says it's a historical
fact
but only for the apprehension of faith
and you might say oh well that's that's
the typical cop out that religious
believers always take
well no because he's actually like
unpacked what faith means within these
metaphysical categories
for you and he says from the eternal
point of view
one does not have faith that the god
exists that is eternally is
even if one assumes that it does exist
the use of the word
faith in this connection enshrines a
misunderstanding
if you want to think that god exists
eternally then you can actually do
philosophical arguments you know
theological
proofs or things along those lines
that's cognition that deals with the
necessity
that deals with the eternal
kicker guard says the historical fact
for a contemporary is that the god has
come into existence
for the member of a later generation the
historical fact that the god has been
present through
having come into existence he walked
among
us he entered into the human world
of meanings and did things and took you
know
a a place at a certain time
did certain acts made choices
says no one can become the immediately
contemporary with this historical fact
it's the object of faith since it
concerns coming into existence
so then he says our historical fact thus
stands before us
it has no immediate contemporary since
it is historical in the first degree
corresponding to faith in the ordinary
sense it has
no immediate contemporary in the second
degree since it's based on a
contradiction remember the paradox
corresponding to faith in the eminent
sense and he says every time the
believer
makes this fact an object of his faith
every time he makes it historical for
himself he reinstates the dialectical
determinations of coming into existence
with respect to it every time the
believer does this
what faith involves is not just some
sort of naive leap into the beyond
but you might say something like a
participation
in what the coming into existence
has made possible for us it realizes for
kierkegaard
something that's most worked into the
possibilities of our humanity
you might say so this is where we're
going to leave
off with this we have one more chapter
to go in
this lengthy excursion into kicker
guard's philosophical fragments